voici
le dernier combat de ma vie d'athlète
nous sommes à tempérer en 2006 en
finlande et je suis face à la japonaise
arai c'est la finale et j'aurai le
bonheur de rang perdre remporté cette
ultime combat
si je devais résumer mes 15 ans de
carrière ce serait si sans combat l'umih
lors d'entraînements
seize mille heures de karaté 600 mille
coups de pied cinq cent cinquante mille
coups de poing si sans protection on se
protège dents perdues 40 kimono 60
paires de baskets 50 survêtement 36 pays
visités enfin du moins leur gymnase et
leur et leur hôtel 5 heures d'attentes
dans le toilettes du contrôle antidopage
à attendre que la miction veulent bien
venir deux tonnes de sucres lents
l'énergie fondamental pour s'exprimer
sur le tatami c'était aussi une fracture
6.2 six points de suture 200 hématome d
une vingtaine de deux tendinites chevy
poignet
c'est aussi des des heures et des 600
900 heures d'ostéopathie de
kinésithérapie et aussi le karaté étant
une jeune discipline olympique
mais aussi une discipline amateurs donc
c'est la précarité
j'ai dû travailler à temps partiel pour
subvenir à mes besoins tout ça pour cent
vingt secondes de combat plutôt
contraignant non mais la plus grande est
la première de mes contraintes
c'était le karaté parce que je ne
voulais pas en faire et c'est par amour
pour mon père que à 12 ans je les ai
suivis aux deux jours alors que moi je
dansais heureusement soul et binou
provençaux et là d'une nature plutôt
timide introverti donc pas très bavarde
et assez solitaire je me retrouve dans
un univers où on ne demande de crier de
frapper et de le faire avec des
personnes que je n'avais pas choisi
j'ai beaucoup pleuré c'était assez
violent pour moi de nous retrouver face
à l'autre et d'être dans cette
obligation de le frapper à chaque en
combat à chaque coup que je porte et je
n'avait de cesse de m'excuser en pensant
que je n'avais pas suffisamment contrôlé
ma technique
ou alors lors des passages de grades il
m'est arrivé à maintes fois de perdre
totalement mes moyens
en exécutant ce qu'on appelle un kata ce
sont des techniques face à un adversaire
imaginaire en étant complètement démuni
face à mon professeur à ses assistants
et à tous les élèves avec qui je
pratique le karaté mais c'était pour moi
le moyen de m'exprimer sans avoir besoin
de parler
et ça m'a permis d'être dans un dans un
dans l'action et dans une action plutôt
vertueuse et positive qui vous en avoir
conscience c'était finalement plutôt
bonne pour moi puis vient le temps des
compétitions j'ai 16 ans je suis
encouragée en fer et j'entre en équipe
de france je suis rigoureuse
je travaille je fais preuve d'abnégation
je suis aussi perfectionniste et à ma
première compétition mon premier
championnat du monde
c'était en afrique du sud à sun city
je finis quatrième pas mal me direz vous
sauf que je n'avais pas plus confiance
en moi j'étais stressée anxieuse je
doutais de mes capacités de mon
potentiel je me jugeais en permanence
j'avais peur du regard qu'on porte et à
ce que je faisais et je
j'avais aussi la peur de mal faire
j'aime à trois ans je suis dans l'avion
qui me mène au japon pour participer à
la coupe du monde féminine
et là je me demande ce que je fais là je
me dis je vais parcourir 9500 km pour
arriver le mercredi soir à tokyo
combattre et en chine est un combat
complètement jet lag et le samedi
revenir à paris le dimanche blessés je
suis dans une sorte d'errance et
finalement je me demande pourquoi je
fais du karaté jusqu'à ce que je fasse
la rencontre de masques alors pour moi
il y avait un petit peu de ces deux
personnages que je vois que vous avez
aussi identifié
mais dans cette rencontre qui a été
importante
ils étaient compétiteurs ils avaient
formé un grand nombre de champions et à
ma grande surprise il me dit laurence la
compétition c'est parce qu'il ya de plus
important
il me dit c'est ça fait partie d'un
cycle
ça fait partie d'une énergie fait partie
d'une mètres de ta maturité à ce moment
là et ça doit juste être un twitter ça
doit être quelque chose qui va t'aider à
consolider les valeurs que tu acquise
par la pratique à te donner des repères
en tant qu'être humain en tant que femme
et il me dit maintenant cherche hockey
et c'est vrai qu'il m'a donné accès à la
culture martial il m'a donné accès à sa
spiritualité ozen
il m'a offert une vision en 3d où ça m'a
permis d' attiser ma curiosité
ça m'a permis d'avoir cette soif
d'apprendre qui m'a amené à donner du
sens à ma pratique
alors quand je travaillais j'ai
travaillé dans un autre état d'esprit
ce qui fait que par exemple mon stress
et mon anxiété se traduisait par je
n'arrivais pas à contrôler ma
respiration jeu en compétition je
perdais beaucoup d'énergie à cause de
cela mais il m'a dit bon maîtriser sa
respiration on était à près de marseille
à l'époque est très bien je vais
t'initier à l'apnée
j'avais ce qu'on appelle le complexe du
sportif et mais je considérais que les
études c'était pas pour moi là aussi des
études à 28 ans je les ai reprises et
j'ai intégré les seuils légaux oui bien
sûr mais surtout pas centrer
l'humilité absolument car tu aura
toujours quelqu'un de plus fort que toi
l'intégrité physique et morale
tout à fait c'est ce qui va te permettre
de vivre plus longtemps et en bonne
santé
le respect de soi le respect des autres
oui mais alors sans se faire aucun
cadeau sur le tatami et c'est
paradoxalement ce qui a fait que des
amitiés se sont créées et que tous ces
faits avec beaucoup de loyauté et tout
ça pour nous dire que finalement
atteindre les sommets
oui mais sans que ce soit la finalité ce
qui compte est et ce qui compte toujours
c'est le chemin et si durant l'ascension
je suis arrêté une blessure des combats
perdus
la rencontre de personnes plutôt
malveillantes et bien le fait d'être
dans cet état d'esprit
le fait de jeu faire face à l'épreuve
vraiment de manière complètement
différente trouver des solutions en se
servant de ses contraintes que je que je
vous ai cités et devant servir
est-ce que ce soit une force aller à
l'essentiel
aller à l'essentiel en faisant appel à
ce que j'ai de plus animal de plus
organique pour me permettre d'être
pleinement dans l'action et d'être
profondément moi même me libérer de ma
condition
en frappant en frappant encore en
acceptant l'émotion qui arrive en
l'identifiant parce qu'on la laisse
aller jusqu'au bout pour l'identifier et
pour à la fin la maîtrise et laisser
l'imagination et la création ne guidez
ne plus penser mais simplement être dans
l'action et cette action là me fait
exploser toutes les toutes les peurs que
je peux avoir et être moi même je sais
qui je suis et en fait je sais que je
suis une femme forte que je l' ai
toujours été et le karaté m'a permis
d'en avoir conscience
et quand j'ai arrêté ma carrière que
j'ai raccroché mon kimono de compétition
qu'aujourd'hui je vous fais cette ce
constat à la manière de ce que ça m'a
apporté
g j'ai un autre combat un très grand
combat pour lequel je me suis engagé
c'est celui de la défense des droits
humains et en particulier celui des
femmes activistes avec ce que je sais
faire de mieux
le sport la transmission par l'action il
est vrai que quand j'étais athlète
j'ai pu constater subi des injustices
des inégalités et j'ai été sensible
ça m'a parfois mis en colère mais
j'étais porté par l'élan du haut niveau
parce je me suis pas arrêté mais j'ai
travaillé l'art de l' esquive la et
celui de l' attaque dans la tacc est
assez récemment j'ai rencontré j'ai fait
une rencontre encore une fois les
rencontres d'un homme extraordinaire il
est gynécologue obstétricien congolais
il s'appelle denis mukwege est-ce
peut-être que vous le connaissez et
c'est un homme qui m'a mis face à
l'inhumain face à la barbarie face à
l'inacceptable et c'est en la matière le
viol utilisé comme arme de guerre
j'ai rencontré les femmes qui l'a soigné
pour les appels et survivante
pour information le congo en 2010 enfin
la république démocratique du congo a
été considérée
et je pense que malheureusement il est
toujours comme la capitale mondiale du
viol
à savoir que 1100 femmes sont violées
chaque jour donc fort de ce constat et
de cette rencontre je me suis moi aussi
associés à cette lutte au combat du
docteur en fondant fight for dignity
aujourd'hui ce sont des femmes victimes
mais aussi de plus en plus d'enfants et
de bébés des viols impunis des victimes
stigmatiser rejetés par leur communauté
nous avons donc ça c'est c'est le pays
où tout se passe nous avons des victimes
qui peuvent aussi être atteintes du vih
qui aussi peuvent à l'issue du viol
avoir des enfants
est ce qu'à fait le docteur mukwege
c'est que après les soins médicaux
apportés pour celles qui sont les plus
en difficulté il aura proposé ce qu'on
appelle une maison transit une maison où
elles peuvent se reposer ou elles ont
accès à l'école gratuitement à des
formations professionnalisantes où elles
ont accès aux soins médicaux
gratuitement elles peuvent aussi avoir
accès ce qu'ont à la musicothérapie et
dans ce cadre-là fight for dignity a mis
en place un programme de karaté et de
foot adapté à leurs traumatismes ou on
permet aux femmes de se réapproprier
leur corps par par cette pratique en le
connectant à leur mental
donc je vais régulièrement au congo et
là c'est en une vingtaine de femmes qui
chaque année une fois par semaine
pratique avec elle pratique évidemment
la première chose à laquelle on pense
c'est la défense l'autodéfense
mais évidemment vous pensez bien que
c'est beaucoup plus que cela elles font
elles apprennent et font des exercices
de respiration de relaxation on
travaille le périnée
on joue on partage pour leur donner est
gelé pour l'entraîner plus confiance en
elle pour qu'elle retrouve l'estimé de
soi pour qu'elle retrouve le goût de la
vie et ça évidemment je le fais avec
franck qui transmet à lui aussi à son
tour à ces femmes et toute l'année et ce
qui est vraiment formidable c'est que
aujourd'hui zawadi sandra agnès veulent
enseigner ont germé en elle une graine
d'espoir
cette graine là elles veulent la
transmettre
et ça marche
et fight for dignity cet espoir là
ovale
vanu aussi le transmettre à d'autres
structures médicalisées demain en france
très demain en afghanistan au sud-soudan
en colombie
pour que cet espoir là
continue et puisse aider encore plus de
femmes
[Applaudissements]